[Music]
this podcast is brought to you by Trello
during tough times like these one thing
that brings us together of course is our
common humanity and another which helps
to harness that is technology now more
than ever
teams must come together and work
together virtually to handle challenges
opportunities and everything in between
that's why Trello is here to help Trello
part of Atlassian collaborative suite is
an app with an easy-to-understand visual
format and tons of features that make
working with your team more functional
and more fun teams of all shapes and
sizes and companies like Google fender
as in Fender guitars and even Costco all
use Trello to collaborate and get work
done it's one of the few tools that has
also made the cut with my team and I
just have a handful of folks so it can
work all the way from tiny to gigantic
with Trello you can work with your team
wherever you are whether it's at home or
in an office and no matter what device
you're using computer tablet or phone
Trello syncs across all of them so you
can stay up to date on all of the things
your team cares about so keep your
workflow going from wherever you are
with Trello try Trello for free and
learn more at Trello comm slash TFS
that's TR e ll o comm slash TFS Trello
comm slash TFS check it out
this episode is brought to you by
nutribullet I have my nutribullet about
seven feet away from me right now I'm
going to be using it for a bunch of
stuff tonight and probably tomorrow
night nutribullet is the affordable easy
to use easy to clean the easy to clean
part is super important blender that was
first recommended to me by entrepreneur
Noah Kagan when I interviewed him for
this podcast and specifically what I
asked him was what is the purchase that
you've made in the last say six months
for $100 or less that has had the
greatest positive impact on your life
and his answer was the nutribullet
nutribullet has sold more than 60
million units worldwide you can start to
do the math on that it's pretty freaking
bonkers and once you've used one it's
easy to understand why it became so
popular with other blenders cleanup can
it be a huge pain in the ass
nutribullet makes it really really
really really simple and if you're not
familiar with the classic nutribullet
it's effectively a single serve cup that
blends and then you flip it upside down
you detach it and you can drink it eat
it chug it down right there so it is
intended for at least in the classic
sense smaller portion sizes but give me
a second here so with your two bullet as
I mentioned cleanup is truly hassle-free
and their signature blending process
transforms whatever you might have high
fiber veggies nuts seeds fruits of
course into silky nutrient-dense
smoothies if that's what you like that
are easy to digest and absorb I use them
for nut butters I use the nutribullet
for soups of different types
I use it for all sorts of stuff now the
engineers at nutribullet have created a
convenient and upgraded version of the
nutribullet called the nutribullet
blender combo this is their most
versatile device yet because it allows
you to switch between single serve as I
was describing and full size blending
it's also a bit more expensive of course
than the classic version but it gives
you a lot more and from smoothies and
protein shakes to savoury soups and dips
the nutribullet blender combo does it
all and there is a recipe book that
comes with it there's all sorts of stuff
that you can play with this
next gen nutribullet gives you
everything you know and love about the
classic - vice yes I'm reading copy in
this particular sentence plus all the
performance and capacity you would
expect from a full-size blender
don't settle for blenders that leave
your smoothies filled with chunks or
anything filled with chunks that you
don't want chunks in get the nutribullet
blender combo and introduce your veggies
and fruits and whatever else you might
have to 1200 Watts it easily just
smashes the living hell out of them and
blends into whatever you would like to
create and for you my dear listeners
nutribullet is offering 20% off of all
products on their website to get your
20% off just go to nutribullet dot-com
forward slash Tim that's nutribullet n
UT RI bul le T comport / Tim if you
don't have a nutribullet in your kitchen
you are missing out it does a lot in a
very small package nutribullet com
forward slash Tim four-year 20% off
hello boys and girls this is Tim Ferriss
and welcome to another episode of the
Tim Ferriss show where it is my job to
deconstruct world class performers of
all different types whether from
business science chess it doesn't really
matter what we're looking for our habits
routines thought patterns frameworks etc
that you can hopefully ponder and test
and apply in your own lives and my guest
today and I'm going to Massacre this
name but I will do my best
is dr. Vivek Murthy that's mu rth why on
Twitter at Vivek Murthy
that's Vivek underscore Murthy on
Facebook Instagram at dr. Vivek Murthy
and Vivek Murthy calm dr. Murthy served
as the 19th Surgeon General of the
United States between 2014 2017 as the
Vice Admiral the US Public Health
Service commissioned corpse he commanded
a uniformed service of 6600 public
health officers globally during his
tenure dr. Murthy launched the turned
the tide campaign catalyzing a movement
among health professionals to address
the nation's opioid crisis he also
issued the first surgeon general's
report on alcohol drugs and health
calling for expanded access for
prevention and treatment and for
recognizing addiction as a chronic
almost not a character flaw in 2017 dr.
Murthy focused his attention on chronic
stress and loneliness as prevalent
problems that have profound implications
for health productivity and happiness
he has co-founded a number of
organisations visions in hiv/aids
education program in India swass Thea a
Community Health Partnership in rural
India training women as health providers
and educators software company trial
networks and the grassroots physicians
organization doctors for America since
leaving government service dr. Murthy
has continued to focus on loneliness and
social connection his brand-new book is
titled together subtitle the healing
power of human connection in a sometimes
lonely world dr. Murthy received his
bachelor's degree from Harvard and his
MD and MBA degrees from Yale he
completed his internal medicine
residency at Brigham and Women's
Hospital in Boston and later joined
Harvard Medical School's faculty in
internal medicine his research focused
on vaccine development and later on the
participation of women and minorities in
clinical trials dr. Murthy welcome to
the show thanks so much Tim it's great
to be on with you I have really enjoyed
getting to know you over the last
handful of years and I thought we should
start with how to pronounce your name
properly and I know we had a warm up we
had a warm up pre-recording but perhaps
you could describe how you have trained
people to say your name in the past I'm
happy to well there were many years
where I just gave up and didn't correct
people but when I was in business school
I started teaching people to say my name
the following way it's printed spelled
VI ve k and the VI is pronounced like
the VI and Victor and the ve K is
pronounced fake so rounds it rhymes with
Lake so that's what I used to tell
people but instead of calling me Vivek
they just called me Victor Lake for the
next two years so much for that well we
have a lot that we can explore and a lot
we will explore and I thought we could
start with loneliness and that is
certainly a perennial topic this is
something that I have struggled with
personally over decades certainly
struggled with as a kid this is
something that also many people are
acutely struggling with because of
Tsarskoe to kovat 19 at the moment and
to place things in context we're
recording this on March 24 2020 both of
us are at home and it will have time to
talk about certainly kovat 19 and so on
and we'll dive into that but I'd like to
focus on loneliness first and let's
start at the beginning
is this a topic of interest to you
because it is something personal that
you have experience with or is it from
observing the impact of loneliness on
health on a wider scale well Tim you
know my interest in this initially
stemmed from my own personal experience
and I'll tell you a little bit about
that but I'll just say that I think when
a lot of people are lonely they don't
realize how common it is and they can
think that it's just them and somehow
their loneliness is evidence that
they're just not likable or evidence of
a character flaw or maladjustment but
the reality is that there are a lot of
people I came to see Andrea with later
years who struggle with loneliness we're
and we're all around each other just in
silence and often feeling a bit ashamed
of how we feel for me the feelings of
loneliness began in elementary school
you know I was a pretty shy kid growing
up and you know I wanted to hang out
with other kids it wasn't that I wanted
to be alone and by myself but I just had
a hard time kind of getting
conversations started and breaking in to
other cliques and into the in-group and
that persisted for a long time and I
still remember going to elementary
school and feeling this pit in my
stomach when my parents would drop me
off and I wasn't scared about tests or
teachers I was just worried about going
to the cafeteria and not knowing who to
sit what I was worried about being on
the playground as the last person picked
for a team despite the fact that I was
actually quite athletic and had good
athletic skill I was worried about
feeling lonely
and I would wait every day until three
o'clock when the bell rang in elementary
school and then I was this feeling of
relief I could finally go back home
where I knew I was loved and where
relationships were just so easy you know
my parents and my sister were just the
best and continued to be just
extraordinary loving family members to
me but that was my first experience of
loneliness and you know it's funny that
how these experiences stick with you for
years and years and years even later in
life when I was able to build beautiful
friendships and feel quite secure in my
relationships I still felt sensitive to
those experiences of being lonely or
sensitive about being in circumstances
where I might be by myself so it's taken
a while to process and work through some
of those feelings and what what does
that look like for you as an adult is
that something that you're able to
compartmentalize or put on the side for
instance for a period of time were you
reminded of this I'm just making this up
this isn't something you've said but for
instance looking closely at the opioid
crisis and a lot of let's let's call it
comorbidity with depression or other
types of conditions that might be
associated with perceived loneliness how
did how did this come to play out in
your adult life yeah so you played out
in two ways in my adult life you know
the first was in a really direct way so
as I got older you know I was able to
build friendships in high school I
enjoyed those friendships I I felt like
I started to to blossom socially in
terms of becoming a person on the
outside who I felt like I was on the
inside but they were still patches you
know in my life where I felt lonely it
was a state that was easy to fall back
into and it was a state that was self
reinforcing you know in a way when I
felt lonely I would actually get down on
myself I would draw even further from
other people which would deepen the
loneliness but there was a second thing
that was happening when I was an adult
which is that I was going through my
medical training and starting to
encounter patients in the clinic and in
the hospital and I trained in internal
medicine and I assumed that the people I
would be seeing and caring for
would have issues like diabetes or heart
disease or infections like pneumonia or
complications of their cancer treatment
and I'd certainly saw many patients with
with those conditions but what I did not
expect to see were so many patients who
were alone and this is how it first
showed up I began seeing patients who
would be admitted to the hospital and
wouldn't have anybody with them and I
would often ask you know in the just
routine course of taking an initial
history and physical I would ask about
there are social circles you know do
they live alone at home I do they have
and somebody that they can rely on in
terms of friends or families in the area
and I was finding often that people were
saying no there's nobody there so that
was one thing but then when urgent
situations would come up when we would
get a test result for example that was
really concerning that showed maybe
somebody had a new diagnosis of cancer
and I would want to talk it through with
them I would often ask them easier
somebody you want us to call so that we
can you share this information together
so you have some supports we can make
some tough decisions together and very
often people would say I wish there was
but there's nobody there even times to
him at the end of life where on many
occasions it was just me and my
colleagues my fellow doctors and nurses
who were the only witnesses to people's
passing away and those really struck me
deeply because in those most important
moments in life you know birth death and
the critical moments you know in between
when you either have success at work or
have major breakups etc you hope that
there will be people there for you
though you'll be surrounded by the
people you love but for so many of these
people there was nobody at the end and
that that was a very heavy feeling that
lingered with me for for a long time and
so I came to see in my adult life that
not only was loneliness something that
continued to affect me in waves
including during the time I was Surgeon
General but it was also something that I
was encountering quite commonly among
the patients I cared for
keep in mind him I had no training in
how to deal with loneliness there was no
class on loneliness in medical school it
was not really part of our curricula to
think about
how to ask people deeply about their
social connections so I felt out of my
league in a sense that I was
encountering problems that I frankly had
no idea how to solve but they seemed
important because they kept coming up
and they seemed to fill people with
sadness I would love to ask you about
several facets of what you what you just
shared the first is being the only
person or along with your colleagues the
only people with someone who is going to
die or who is in palliative care I
suppose those are synonymous or who has
just been given a very grave diagnosis I
found you over the last handful of years
to be very calm very soothing and I'd be
curious to know what you did in those
circumstances to help these people
psychologically what types of things
would you say what would you do are
there any particular examples that
spring to mind that were difficult I'd
love to just if you're open to it talk
about really any any specific example
that that jumps to mind because that's
that strikes me as a potentially
difficult circumstance to navigate and I
don't know how how long these people
were in the hospital but it's possible
that they'd been alone or felt alone for
a long time and really the the strongest
tether they had at the time of the
diagnosis or before passing would be
with you or one of your colleagues so I
just be very interested to hear you
speak to that yeah you know those
moments Tim are are so so so deeply
etched in my memory because they were
they were they impacted me a great deal
as well but you know in those moments
you know as a doctor you're trained to
use your head and your heart but I found
in those moments in particular that I
had to get completely out of my head and
just try to fully unhappen my heart and
be there not as a doctor but as a human
being and I do think that all of us
regardless of what stage of life were on
we have we've got three basic needs we
all want to
know that we matter we want to be seen
for who we are and we want to know that
we're loved and in those moments what I
tried my best to do was to help people
feel that they were seen just simply by
sitting there and focusing on them and
listening to them by putting my pager
aside by not standing at the doorway but
actually pulling up a chair and sitting
with them by holding their hand often on
the physical contact is such an
important part of our human connection
and I try to just listen to whatever it
was that they wanted to talk about and
there were times where I struggle that
felt like you know maybe I should say
something insightful or thoughtful or or
empathic but when I would look back on
those conversations I think the most
important part was just showing up and
being there and being fully present so
that's what I I tried to do and you know
I had this ritual that I would do also
like when they passed which is you know
when a patient passes away you're always
called as a doctor to pronounce them and
so you have to document that the heart
has stopped that there's no corneal
reflex and there are a series of steps
that you have to take like that and so I
would do that but I would also then take
him a minute I just stand by their
bedside in silence with them and to just
imagine sort of like the energy you know
of the universe just washing over them
you know with love and with kindness and
that was my special moment with them and
even though they passed I would like to
I would hope that it was meaningful for
their spirit it was certainly meaningful
for me but those are some of the things
that I would try to do at the end of
life I don't know if they mattered or
made a huge difference in people's lives
but I hope that it may have eased the
pain of their passing just a little bit
thank you for sharing that how do you
think about your own mortality or relate
to mortality and I won't get I don't
mean to take this in a metaphysical or
esoteric direction but as someone who is
witnessed a fair amount of death and no
doubt thought about the finite time that
you have on this planet at least for now
how do you relate to mortality or think
about it
that's a really good question um you
know I think I think about my mortality
often not in a morbid way but in a way
that I hope will remind me to appreciate
the present moment you know when I was
in residency training
I remember one week being on the
oncology service where half of the
patients I was taking care of or young
people in their 20s who had end-stage
gastric cancer and I was in my 20s at
the time and it was really a stark
experience for me because I could have
been lying in that bed instead of them
like these were accidents of fate and so
there's something about training in
medicine in those years and then caring
for patients afterward that made me
continually recommit to trying to be as
present as I could recognizing that you
know tomorrow's not guaranteed we don't
know how long we have with the people we
love but but we can make choices today
to dramatically improve the quality of
our life and the depth of our happiness
and so when I think about my mortality I
think I try to think about being fully
present now I try to think you know
after that my residency training I I
made a significant change for example in
how I spent a short time so I made it a
point to try to come home to see my
family in Miami every two to three
months prior to that I used to go about
twice a year and there's no right number
of visits to make to one's family but
for me I realized that I wanted to be
there as often as I could for the people
who had given everything so that I could
live the life that I have and to me that
was well worth it and I look back on my
life you know we all look back in our
life when we wonder if he made the right
decisions and I am the same I'm not
always sure I made the right decisions
on things but in that one area I feel
like yes that was the right thing to do
to come see them more often so yeah you
know as a dad it's a little different
now also I think about more immortality
and it's bittersweet because I think
about the things I may miss if I'm not
here in terms of my children's major
milestones in life they're moments of
great joy and
penis I want them to find true love in
life I want to be there when that
happens I think about those moments and
with the tinge of sadness I would be sad
to not be there but that makes me all
the more want to live my life in a way
where the time I'm spending right now is
time well spent
I'll focus on relationships and focus on
giving and receiving love there's a
fantastic essay if people listening have
not read it by Tim Urban called the
tail-end that I certainly recommend
everybody read that had the same impact
on me in in the sense that I ended up
dramatically increasing the amount of
time per year that that I spent with
parents in particular and also my
brother if you don't mind I'd love to
zoom out just to provide some context
and maybe define what this what the
Surgeon General does and I would love to
hear you describe the role of the
Surgeon General and then how and why you
ended up the Surgeon General well this
is a good thing to talk about because I
think very few people actually know what
the Surgeon General does even though
many people know the position exists and
that frankly includes people in
government who don't necessarily know
what the Surgeon General does even
though they may have a working
relationship with the office of the
Surgeon General so I'll tell you when I
actually became Surgeon General it was a
fascinating process which I'm happy to
to talk about but at very few if any
points in all of the conversations I had
with people in the administration did
somebody sit down and say okay this is
what your job will entail so one of the
first things I did when I became Surgeon
General as I went to the general counsel
at the Department of Health and Human
Services and I said you know look I have
a sense of what I want to do a search in
general of what the job entails but what
I really want to know is what is the law
actually say about what my job is
because everyone seems to have a
different idea here and so what the law
says is it says that the job of the
Surgeon General is to be the commanding
officer overseeing the
United States Public Health Service
commissioned Corps so this is one of the
uniformed services and the United States
government alongside the army the Navy
the Air Force and the other uniformed
services and the officers in the
commissioned Corps are doctors and
nurses and public health engineers and
physical therapists and other health
practitioners but overseeing that
service and serving as the Vice Admiral
of that service is the statutory
responsibility but there's another
responsibilities evolve over time which
is that the Surgeon General is supposed
to provide the public with the best
possible information on health so people
can make good decisions for themselves
and their families and that's taken on
many forms some surgeons general have
published reports and surgeon dollar
reports have become these iconic
publications that spark major changes in
policy and in practice all around the
world others have taken to being out in
the public often to give issue PSAs and
to talk to people directly about steps
they can take to be healthier but all of
this comes down to the fact that the job
itself is actually quite flexible and
that was one of the things that I I've
certainly appreciated about it is that
unlike most other political appointees
your allegiance is not to the president
your allegiance and in your highest
responsibility is to the public and to
science and I like that so if there's a
disagreement between what the president
says and what science says you're
supposed to side with science even if
that puts you at risk of being fired so
I liked that I like being able to create
your own agenda and being you know sort
of attuned to what the people want and
be out there in communities across the
country that really spoke to me it was
exciting to me and one of the reasons I
ultimately felt the the job was a good
fit when would a listener if ever
encounter one of these 6,000 plus public
health officers who were under your
command so to speak as Vice Admiral I
I'm just wondering what in what context
we can imagine these people working have
and I asked in part because I'm hearing
currently of course this is late March
of the National Guard potentially
building field hospitals and so on so
would would they end up in at a field
hospital or are they working exclusively
in government and don't have contact
with civilians could you describe what
types of work that that uniformed
service of six thousand plus do yes so
they do a variety of jobs throughout the
federal government so some are stationed
at this Centers for Disease Control and
Prevention the CDC some are at the Food
and Drug Administration some are at NIH
the National Institutes of Health so
they are throughout the Department of
Health and Human Services but they also
work at other agencies in government
they provide a lot of the health care in
the Bureau of prisoners to people who
are incarcerated they also work in the
National Park Service to help guide the
Department of Interior on matters
related to health when you may have
encountered so these are the people just
to keep in mind who helped build and
preserve and execute the infrastructure
for Public Health throughout the country
where you may have encountered them are
actually during times of crisis
so we deploy our officers to disaster
areas when there's a major hurricane or
a tornado that comes through or a major
flood after 9/11 we sent many officers
in New York to help provide basic
medical care and to help stand up the
medical and public health infrastructure
when the Ebola crisis hit in in the
Obama administration we sent hundreds of
officers to Liberia to help open what
was called the Monrovia medical unit and
provide direct care to people there and
the reason we did that was because prior
to setting up the Monrovia medical unit
countries around the world were not
sending their volunteers until iberia
even though the Ebola outbreak was
ramping up added at a really scary pace
but they weren't doing that because they
were worried their volunteers would get
sick and no one would be there to take
care of them but when we set up that
unit when these commissioned corps
officers started caring for people then
countries opened the floodgates
that if they remember volunteers got
sick someone would be there to care for
them so these are some of the many
circumstances in which you see
commissioned Corps officers and but you
know they are often invisible we talk
about them as one of the best-kept
secrets in the US government personally
I don't think they should be a secret I
think they should actually be much more
out there and visible and that's
something is leadership we've got to do
a better job on but they are a critical
part of our of our health infrastructure
in the country if we take a closer look
at the Ebola crisis for a second what
was the term you used the Monroe vien
I'm blanking Task Force Monrovia the
Monrovia medical unit there we go
medical unit what was it like making
that happen was that difficult to create
this tip of the spear slash Vanguard to
to go to Liberia was was that
challenging to navigate sort of in
inside the Machine of the United States
government or was that relatively
straightforward or somewhere in between
what was that experience like for you
well it was a very complicated
experience and it was an experience an
endeavor that was begun shortly before I
entered office and that continued long
after I got there but it was not easy
for us to pull together because it
required a fair amount of legal work to
make sure that we had the authorities to
go abroad and set up a medical unit like
that that was one piece of it second is
we had to think and deeply about how to
make sure that these officers who had
not been deployed to West Africa before
had the training the support they needed
to be effective and to achieve and
accomplish the mission but we also you
know had to deal with real human factors
factors that affect any soldier a
uniformed officer who goes overseas
during the theatres of war and whether
that war is with visible soldiers or
invisible agents like the Ebola virus
which is that there's trauma that comes
with it as well and it took us a while
to get out a full I think handle around
the extent of the trauma that was
involved that officers experienced when
they went abroad into knowing that their
life was on the line and tried to care
for people who had
so these were complicated missions
they're also complicated because in
government while government has powerful
mechanisms for you know implementing
change they're complicated mechanisms
they're big ships it turns slowly and
having to move quickly without breaking
something having to collaborate with
multiple arms you know of the uniformed
services especially the Army in West
Africa and with you know the legislative
branch and the executive branch this was
this took a lot of conversations a lot
of collaboration a lot of putting out
fires so it was messy you know behind
the scenes you know this the
sausage-making often is but it was worth
doing because it was a key part of
turning the tide on the Ebola crisis if
you don't mind I'd love to chat a little
bit about the the pink elephant in the
room which is just for sake of
simplicity I'll call Cove it 19 I
understand there's a virus and then
there's the disease and so on and so
forth but how are you currently thinking
about Cove in 19 what are people missing
or misunderstanding or really what would
you like to share in terms of your
thinking related to Cove at 19 there's
so much that Cove in 19 is teaching us
not just about science and health but
about our infrastructure and about
society more broadly one of the key
things to recognize about Koba 19 is as
we're having this conversation we've
learned a lot about the virus but
there's still a lot we don't know
you know there's several weeks ago when
during the early days of this outbreak
there was an assumption that young
people don't have much to worry about
and that this is an illness that
primarily affects the elderly and those
with other complicated medical
conditions but the data that we're
starting to get now shows that perhaps
that distinction was too stark and that
in fact younger people are more affected
and get more seriously ill than we had
previously thought so this is a humbling
virus it's teaching us new things about
it and we've got to keep that in mind
and and make sure that we approach it
with caution and that we err on the side
of being too cautious and too aggressive
in addressing it
you know I think the second thing that's
important to realize about you know
about code 19 is that this virus is not
the flu this is a very different virus
it's much more contagious it's much more
deadly and we don't have any tools in
terms of medications or vaccines to
address it at the current moment and
hopefully that will change over time but
right now we don't have those tools and
we also don't have natural immunity in
the population because this hasn't been
circulating for years you know I think
the other part to remember here is that
every now and then there's a moment in
the world's history where we are faced
with a challenge that's far bigger than
any one of us or than any one country
can solve on its own and Coban 19 has
presented us with one of those
challenges and the question is how are
we going to respond you know as a world
how are we going to collaborate to not
only in develop therapeutics but also to
help each other overcome shortages of
masks and other protective equipment how
are we going to share data so that we
can learn together about how to prevent
catastrophe as the virus spreads across
the world it's a real test you know of
the relationships that we have between
countries but it's also and I think
perhaps more poignant Lia a test of the
relationships we have in our communities
you know we're coming to realize that
with a virus itit spreads really easily
where there is no treatment yet one of
our most effective mechanisms of
preventing spread is to physically
distance people as painful as that is as
lonely as that can be it is one of the
more effective strategies and so as we
speak we're currently implementing that
you know here in the United States and
is not an easy thing to do but one of
the things that it's already started to
illuminate and remind many of us of is
that we really do need each other but as
much as we live in a world that and in a
country I should say that's built on an
ethic of individual responsibility and
that's built on a narrative of the
single entrepreneur who builds the
company or the single scientists who
solves you know a major disease and
finds a cure the reality is
we are far more interdependent and
interconnected than perhaps those
narratives might suggest and I think
that this experience of Cobie 19 is a
powerful reminder of that you know and
finally Tim I think it's Carville Cobie
19 is pushing us to confront some messy
difficult but important questions and
questions around what we believe people
need to support them and what role
government has in providing those
supports so in a scenario like this for
example when somebody may get sick and
they've got to stay home for a couple of
weeks because they have Co b19 infection
what if they don't have paid sick leave
then how did they take care of their
child and make sure that he or she is
food on the table if they're an uber or
a lyft driver and they're depending on
that income in order to help put their
child through college or take care of an
elderly relative what do they do when
nobody's out on the road taking rides
because they're worried about safety the
truth is we we don't have as robust a
net in to catch people and support
people when they fall as we perhaps may
have thought we had in the United States
and so this I think is a deeper moment
for us to grapple with that and to ask
well if we truly are interdependent how
can we best support each other as
individuals and as a government what do
we need to do to ensure that people have
the best shot at living a healthy and
fulfilled life
it certainly is bringing up a lot of
inconvenient and important questions
some of which you mentioned and one hand
it's been very uplifting as a silver
lining to see how much certain
communities have rallied or coalesced
grown stronger as a result of this where
the importance of community and seeing
each other's faces and so on has has
increased and I was I was struck earlier
today I had a team call with my
employees and there was a very fast
rotation where each person spoke about
one thing they were proud of and one
thing they were happy about before
getting into the the business matters
and what came up most often was seeing
communities come together that was that
was the happy about point that came up
the most and I do want to talk about
that I'm gonna ask you about remembering
your anchors and I have a whole host of
other questions that I'd like to ask but
I'd also like to dig into Kovan 19 just
a little bit more if you're open to it
sure yeah and again as a snapshot in
time as we speak
New York City's Javits Center is being
turned into a disaster hospital for
covin 19 patients and or maybe overflow
from other conditions I don't know I
imagine it would probably be dedicated
for code 19 there's there's a lot of
movement right now there are some people
who would argue that the United States
has really been caught on its heels in a
lot of respects and has not taken
aggressive enough actions from the
playbooks of South Korea etc China other
places if you were the benevolent
dictator of the United States and your
team came to you and asked what should
be done at this point in time is there
anything that comes to mind that that
you would you would tell your team well
yes I I would tell them about the the
three important principles that you have
to make sure you adhere to and disaster
response the number one you have to lead
with science in your decision-making and
lead with scientists in your
communication the number two you got to
be transparent with the public even when
it's painful
not only because that's how you build
and maintain trust which is one of the
most important assets you have in
fighting a crisis like this but also
because that transparency creates the
accountability that you need as
government and the third thing I would
tell them is that our job and we've been
more than that our sacred
responsibilities in a crisis like this
when people are putting their lives on
the line is to make sure that we pull
out all the stops they get resources to
people on the front lines and those are
the doctors and nurses and health care
workers and
hospitals those are the public health
workers and communities across the
country who are trying to trace contacts
and coming in contact with people who
are ill those are the individuals who
are impacted economically as we pull
back on social interaction and as
businesses shut down those are the three
principles that have to guide us and in
particular when I think about the
circumstances in our hospitals you know
it's so deeply painful to me because we
we are encountering a pandemic that we
haven't seen the likes of in over a
century and we are not prepared for we
have certainly done some preparation for
major disasters but this is not a
typical disaster this is far greater in
scale and scope and so we right now as
we speak have doctors and nurses who are
reusing masks and hospitals who are
going to see patients in some cases
doing surgeries without masks which is
bad for the doctor and patient but
because there is no other option we have
the hospitals that are running out of
gowns and gloves we have doctors who are
trying to figure out how to take one
ventilator and somehow rig it so that it
can care for two patients at the same
time because they're running out of
ventilators these are the realities that
we're facing in our hospitals today in
2020 in the richest country in the world
and this is sobering you know it's and
it's it's painful to recognize this but
that's the situation that we're in what
that means to me is that we we have to
do everything within our power avail
ourselves of every authority and
mobilize every resource that we have
access to to ensure that we close the
gap between what those healthcare
settings have and what they need because
here's the truth it's not just a moral
responsibility we have to protect those
on the front lines but on a very
practical level as doctors and nurses
start to get sick in larger and larger
numbers because they don't have the
protection they need when they're caring
for sick patients that also pulls people
out of the workforce exactly when we
need them in our hospitals and it
further deepens a crisis
so this is how I would frame the
challenge to my team these responses are
never easy you know I was in the
administration in the federal government
during the Ebola response and during the
Zika response and those are not easy
either we hadn't quite dealt with those
kind of crises before and so you they're
always stumbles like in these instances
but the question is not do you stumble
they think the more important question
is how do you get up how to get up
quickly and how do you learn from your
mistakes and ensure that you are serving
even better as a result of what you've
learned thank you and feel free not to
answer or we can punt but I'd be very
curious adhering to those three
principles of crisis response since
you're the benevolent dictator you can
and you can on some level insist and
enforce those three principles at this
point in time what types of
interventions or actions whether
statewide or nationwide would you be
considering implementing knowing what
you know well so a couple I mean there's
a lot to spend a couple things that come
to mind we have all the time in the
world fortunately this isn't morning TV
a luxury of space take all these more
than 30 seconds to make profound
statements about the world okay that's
great so a couple things I do number one
I would make sure that as the federal
government that we were providing clear
directives to states and localities
about when to pull the trigger on
various measures that they may take to
protect their population including
closing schools shutting down businesses
issuing shelter in place or stay-at-home
orders one of the great challenges that
states and local government struggle
with is how to make these decisions
based on what criteria and what you see
right now is a very uneven response you
know across the country and so people
are confused they're asking well why is
California issuing a stay at home order
but other states aren't even though they
may have a similar number of cases it's
because there's confusion in part and so
that's one thing I would do is to make
sure that
as a federal government we were putting
our nickel down so to speak and
providing clear criteria to states and
local governments about when to
implement some of these restrictions the
second thing that I would do is I would
take the responsibility as a federal
government to make sure that we were
filling the gaps in terms of materials
and space that hospitals needed that
doesn't mean that we have to provide
everything directly ourselves but it
doesn't mean that we need to be
responsible for solving the problem so
if for example New York State and
California State and Washington state
are short on masks it would be
inefficient for them and to spend all of
this time looking for gloves calling
vendors and fective ly competing against
each other for a limited supply this is
a place where it makes sense actually
for the federal government to step in
and to use its power to procure what's
needed and so that's the second place
where I would exercise Authority the
third place where I would do it then the
third area that I would focus on would
be to ramp up domestic production of the
materials that we need particularly
around personal protective equipment for
healthcare workers this includes masks
and gowns and gloves now we have
authorities that the federal government
can use to compel private industry to
produce these products if they're in the
national interest in this case they are
now I think we should only use those
kind of authorities as the last resort
because they are disrupted but part of
what real leadership is about is about
bringing people together to do
voluntarily what we need as a country to
have done and in this case I think if we
had a clear and compelling call to
private industry with clear directives
on what is needed and on the specs for
what needed to be produced I think we
would start to see more and more
businesses voluntarily switch over their
production and start to produce masks
and gloves and gowns this isn't actually
theoretical like even as we speak I've
spent the last five or six days in touch
with multiple companies that have sought
me out and are seeking other public
health experts out saying you know I
have a shirt factory or I have an
apparent another type of apparel Factory
I want to help give me the specs I will
start producing today this is the spirit
you know of America that we're seeing
with people standing up in every corner
of this country raising their hand and
saying how can I help and part of what
we need to do as government is to give
them the opportunities to help to make
it easier for them to step up and to
make a difference so there's a you know
these are just a few of the things I
think that are essential to do right now
but I think one of the the last things
are the really really important role of
government in these kind of crises is to
be in a sense the both of the data
keeper as well as the storyteller let me
explain what I mean by that in moments
like this there are key questions that
people want to know the answer to they
want to know how many people have the
illness how many people have survived
how many people have been tested how
many of those tests are positive are
there shortages of tests anywhere and
how quickly can we meet those shortages
these are data questions and in the
absence of having a clear place where
people can go it makes a response much
harder and we don't have full clarity on
some of these critical data questions
right now but that absolutely needs to
be something that the federal government
steps in to help solve in partnership
with States but the story teller side of
the coin is also very important
storytelling is is is essential it's not
just entertainment it's how we process
events it's how we anchor ourselves you
know in an experience it's how we find
meaning and make sense of really
confusing times and the role of a leader
and a crisis whether it's an individual
leader or an organization like in this
case at the federal government that's
taking the lead is to be able to tell a
clear honest transparent but compelling
story about the journey we've been on
and where we're going you need to be
able to tell people what we've seen and
experience what their real cost of it
are but you also have to provide a
hopeful path forward
and help people see how we can emerge
from this what the path to doing that
actually is and how we can actually get
there together none of these things I've
described very easy but they are
necessary they're essential I during
crises and these are some of the areas
that I would focus on you know if I had
the privilege of serving thank you it's
it's been it's been fascinating to
observe at least on this on the state
level Cuomo's daily briefings which I
think seem to be certainly a step in the
right direction but that would be needed
if I'm hearing you correctly more so on
a on a national on a national level god
I hope we can get our act together I'm
optimistic and pessimistic depending on
the on the hour in which you happen to
catch me but it's it's do you think it
is possible in a country like the United
States and we won't spend too much more
time on the the nitty-gritty of this but
to implement some of the aspects of the
playbooks from countries like say a
South Korea or China that seemed to have
played roles in some what I should say
necessarily completely containing but
lowering the are not of the SARS cough
to in these places for instance you know
there's contact tracing and so on which
seems like it would run into privacy
issues in the United States if we're
using private cell phone data and
geolocation and so on you have say in
South Korea actual penalties in other
words enforcement of shelter at home
which I believe escalated over time to
the point where they got to something
like in the thousands between five and
eight thousand dollars per infraction
and I mentioned that just because a
friend of mine told me that looking at
satellite data of San Francisco after
the shelter-in-place command the foot
traffic was roughly sixty percent of
normal that doesn't strike me it's a
very leaky condom that you're using to
practice safe sex metaphorically
speaking
right so that that doesn't that doesn't
really give me a super high degree of
confidence in a compliant population
without enforcement do you think we are
simply too culturally different and too
politically divided to implement some of
these more some of these stricter
measures or or would you if you could
implement some of these things in the
United States yeah this is their such a
good question and you know some of the
extraordinary public health measures
that have been taken in South Korea and
China to release stem the tide of coving
nineteen would be hard to take care for
for sure but I think what we have in the
United States in in part as a result of
our our cherished preservation of
freedom and individual liberties is as a
government we have a greater burden of
responsibility to ensure that we are
explaining things in making our case to
the public of what needs to be done and
so that is an important but not always
an efficient way to achieve behavior
change you mentioned that foot traffic
in San Francisco is 60% of what it was
after the shelter-in-place order was
issued and that's not that's not good
that's like you know that means that
we're gonna still see continued spread
if there indeed is a lot of virus in the
city which we have reason to believe
there is and so I think the burden of
responsibility on government and on
leaders to really communicate in a clear
and compelling way what has to be done I
think is much greater in in society here
but with that said I do think that there
are moments when the national interest
is threatened where we have to ask
ourselves what trade-offs are necessary
in terms of individual liberties you
know to protect the national interests
and we make these decisions all the time
you know for example we don't say that
individual liberty means that you can
drive whatever speed you want on the
highway you know we don't see that say
that we've also said that individual
freedom doesn't mean and that you can
drive without a seatbelt we've made
mandatory seatbelt laws the thing in
states all across
entry so as much as we may pride
ourselves and being a country that
preserves individual liberty we have
made thoughtful calculated decisions in
many occasions on what trade-offs are
worth it for our own benefit and also
for the public benefit and I think when
it comes to epidemic responses what
we're gonna have to do in the aftermath
of Cobie 19 is I think have a much
deeper discussion about what kind of
trade-offs we need to make to make sure
that something like this does not reek
the kind of havoc on our country that
are very well may and seems poised to do
and if that means that we may need to
consider contact tracing and our
location tracing is part of what you
know needs to be discussed and we should
have that discussion I'm not saying that
everyone should give their data over to
the government but these are the
conversations that we need and debates
that we need to have we also have to ask
ourselves what kind of power we want to
give to different levels of government
like what should a local government be
able to impose in terms of restrictions
on your movements what about a state
government what about a federal
government so these are these are look
these are tough and complicated
questions but I think part of the
challenge we have within difficult
issues in the modern day setting in the
United States is that when things are
difficult because of the polarized
environment in which we live we tend to
move on and just focus on other issues
so we don't deal with climate change
because it has become a politically
polarized issue we don't deal with many
aspects of health care because they've
become politically polarized and I think
that if we really want to overcome that
kind of polarization we actually have to
do the opposite of what we hear
recommended a lot you know I here I live
in Washington DC and I hear many pundits
say well what we really got to do is get
people with different views in the same
room have them really talk to each other
and understand what their points of view
are and then maybe they can find a point
of agreement or convince each other that
really never works the way people
overcome these barriers the way they
sort of bridge the
polarization that they're experiencing
right now is actually by building
relationship first that has nothing to
do with the actual issue at hand whether
its climate change or gun violence or
reproductive rights but when we build a
relationship with each other we're
better able to talk to each other and
listen to each other that's why many of
us who may have an aunt or an uncle or a
grandmother or grandfather who has views
that we find to be disagreeable and
despicable we can still have them over
for Thanksgiving dinner we still want to
have them over we can still respond if
they're in an accident because we deeply
care about them because there's a
foundation which is the relationship on
which we're building our conversations
the problem right now in America is
increasingly we don't have those bonds
between each other we don't have those
relationships to build conversation and
discussion on so what ends up happening
is we're having discussions about
polarized topics with strangers who are
easy to caricature and those discussions
don't often go very well and it's
reflected frankly with what's happening
in Congress where members of Congress
increasingly don't have relationships
with each other and it may it's not a
surprise that it's harder for them to
come together and broker real solutions
for the larger public I've been thinking
quite a lot about this polarization and
what at least temporarily can suspend or
make irrelevant that polarization 9/11
would be perhaps one example these acute
losses of life these are a graphic
events that seem to unite people at
least temporarily to take certain steps
Pearl Harbor probably another fantastic
example right so if Japanese attempt to
destroy Pacific Fleet under estimating
the sort of dynamic qualities and
variables that could change when the
United States United and suddenly
changed all of its production and so on
to then later turn around and sort of
exact then
a thousandfold and I am on some level
darkly optimistic that I mean it sounds
terrible but I you know sort of
anticipating that there could be
something that graphic and an awful
particularly given the nature of every
cell phone having a video and a video
camera and still camera embedded that
would perhaps suspend the polarity the
political polarity long enough to take
really decisive action do you think
there's anything that comes to mind as
it relates to Cove in nineteen that
could act as such a catalyzing event I
mean what what would it take if anything
comes to mind to temporarily give us a
political cease-fire so he could take
really decisive unified action well I do
think Tim that Cove in nineteen could be
a catalyst for greater unity and for
stepping back from the polarization and
part of what gives me hope is that I'm
already starting to see that happen here
and there in communities across the
country as people reach out to each
other and help each other
there's people check-in on neighbors who
are struggling now without anyone to
help them because they're alone and I've
seen even on the local level even though
this doesn't get a lot of press you know
I've seen local officials I'm gonna step
up and put a traditional partisan issues
aside to work together because they
recognize that there's something much
much greater at stake and much more
urgent which is the lives of the people
that they're there to serve and so I do
think it can happen i what i worry about
is is this is does it always have to
take a crisis particularly one that
involves a loss of life and great
suffering for us to realize that we
truly need each other and that we need
to come together and put our collective
well-being over our individual interests
I hope it won't always take that but I
do think that
given the magnitude of what Cova 19 has
already done and what it stands to do to
the United States and to the world that
this could be a wake-up call this could
be an opportunity for people to come
together the real question though Tim is
will they stay together and if you look
back at 9/11 and at many of the
tragedies we've experienced as a country
we do come together and we see in those
moments is I think the actual authentic
intrinsic human spirit which is a spirit
of togetherness a spirit of
interdependence the spirit of compassion
and generosity and joy but that gets
quickly eroded as we settle back into
our day to day lives and there are many
reasons why we settle back and there are
forces I think in the messaging we see
in in media and from work and in the
larger culture which keep pulling us
back I think away from a focus on
relationships you know and what I find
interesting is if you and I went to a
street corner in any major city in the
United States and we pulled a hundred
people aside and we asked them all what
their top priority in life was I can
almost guarantee you that all of them
would have a person as their top
priority maybe their spouse maybe their
child maybe their mother or father but
if we look at how we live our lives if
you look at where we put our time energy
and focus if you look at what society
tells us constitutes success it's
actually very different like the message
that society sends us and I'm pretty
good that young people get through the
various forms of media is that success
is driven by your ability to acquire
wealth power or reputation / fame and if
that is what worth is connected to then
we'll build our lives around that that's
where we'll spend our time that's what
we'll be thinking about when we go to
sleep at night that's what we'll invest
our energy in but in reality I think
what gives us the deepest joy and
fulfillment in our life is actually our
relationships and when I think back on
the people that I had the privilege of
caring for in the hospital at the
and of their life I think a lot about
what they talked about in those final
days and what they talked about were not
the promotions that they received or how
big their bonuses were they didn't talk
about how many followers they had on
Instagram or how many friends they had
in the world what they talked about
really were the quality of their
relationships they talked about the
people they loved about their
relationships they wish they had spent
more time with they talked about the joy
that the people in their life brought
them and I think that is a very powerful
signal to us over what really matters
that's not something that I just I'm
seeing that's something that people in
all walks of life who spend time with
people in the father final days this is
what they focus on the focus on people
and so I think that if we want to
ultimately address the deeper issues
were facing in society whether it's the
polarization we're dealing with whether
it's the challenges we face on the
health front with chronic illness
particularly with mental illness and
with addiction I think we have to ask
ourselves what role does social
connection and loneliness play in the
outcomes that were worried about and
what I have found over the last few
years in thinking about this issue and
talking to people who are I've studied
this for a lifetime
in hearing and listening to the stories
of people all across the world who have
struggled with loneliness but who have
also built lives a rich social
connection is that it is our
relationships that are the foundation on
which we build everything else good
health fulfillment and a good life how
would you suggest as we've been
discussing we've sort of zoomed from the
macro into the micro which is where I
would like to stay for a bit rather than
looking at say the federal level let's
let's talk about a company if you're
talking to a CEO or a c-suite or a
leader of a large group of people within
a company what are things that they can
do to help improve this
of connectedness or worth as a
counterweight to loneliness which I
think that is going to be challenged for
a lot is a challenge for a lot of people
and will increasingly be a challenge for
a lot of people certainly over the next
few weeks and therein lies an
opportunity to sharpen the saw as it
relates to developing countervailing or
counter balancing forces opposing
isolation or loneliness so what types of
tools or advice would you suggest with
business leaders people who run
companies whether it's five people or
500 or 5,000 mm-hm I'm really glad you
asked him because I think that the
workplace is an incredibly powerful
place for us to cultivate human
connection and I think when we don't
have workplaces where people feel like
they have strong relationships that has
a measurable impact on productivity on
retention and on overall satisfaction at
work there are some fascinating
researchers who have been working in
this area including Siegel Barr say that
at Wharton who we found that that
loneliness in the workplace is just as
common as it is in the general
population somewhere the around 2025
percent of people in the workplace seem
to struggle with loneliness and the
consequences are substantial so whether
you care about the bottom line or you
care about the happiness of your
employees loneliness and social
connection matter and I think there are
a couple of things that we can do in
companies that that would really help I
think one is to create opportunities for
people to really see and understand each
other for who they are beyond the roles
that they play in the workplace you know
all of us have a fundamental desire to
want to be seen for who we are not just
as you know Tim who's great at pricing
strategy or Vivek who's good at God I
don't know what I'm good at not sure but
you know we want to be known for more
than a skill set we want to be known as
human beings who got a story I'll tell
you why
was something we did when I was a
Surgeon General is we created this
exercise called the inside scoop
exercise and we did this when after a
year after working really hard to try to
create a family environment in the
office we realized that people still
were not as connected as they could be
despite all of the weekend picnics and
the happy hours and all of that question
before we get to the practice the inside
scoop how did you ascertain that you had
that problem does that make sense like
how did you diagnose that or observe
that before we get to the inside scoop I
want to get there but I want to also
know how you diagnosed it because I
would imagine there are plenty of
business leaders who think everything is
just hunky-dory going along swimmingly
whereas in fact it is it is perhaps not
if you could speak to that yeah so you
know what we didn't do is we didn't have
a very specific survey tool that we use
to assess in a quantitative way whether
people felt connected or not those kind
of tools actually exist but we didn't
use them what we were going on was
actually a more much more simple
observation from my perspective I was
observing the office and feeling that
people were not stepping out of their
lanes enough to help each other now
that's a voluntary thing it's not their
job description to help someone else
with their job but it wasn't happening
to the extent that I thought it should
be happening and I started to wonder why
and to me when I think about the
workplace a lot of my my my thinking
comes back to the model of the family so
in a family people help each other why
do they help each other because they
feel a sense of commitment and
connection to each other because they
know each other deeply so even if
somebody messes up there's a deeper well
of knowledge about who that person is it
makes you more likely to forgive them
and to give them the benefit of the
doubt in a workplace I think you can
ideally create a similar kind of
environment so the fact though that
people were not stepping out of their
Lane enough to help each other made me
think that their connection to each
other was not as strong as what we
wanted it to be and so this inside scoop
exercise that we instituted was actually
very simple it
five minutes in our weekly all staff
meeting where we picked one individual
and we asked him to show us pictures for
those five minutes pictures of anything
they wanted except it couldn't be
connected to the work that they were
doing right now to their current job
some people showed examples of careers
they had before others showed pictures
of their families people picked what
they wanted what was really powerful
about this this matter simple it was is
it gave people a chance to share who
they were without any pressure in the
sense that like we weren't telling them
to like Fitz fill some criteria to
generate some sort of response have a
list of questions that they could pose
to the group there was none of that it
was this very simple show was something
that you'd want us to know about your
life I'll tell you the one gentleman in
particular who is my age at camp and was
in the Marine Corps prior to joining the
Public Health Service we all thought
that he might show pictures of his time
in the Marine Corps you know he was his
strong allegiance to the Marine Corps he
talked about his experiences there a lot
he was also you know very stoic he still
had her same crew cut and hair cut that
he had in the in the Marine Corps he had
maintained you know over all those years
he was what people in the office called
a guy's guy and when the day came though
for his exercise he didn't show pictures
of his time in the service well he
showed were pictures of his mother and
pictures of his father and he said that
he could see the musical talent of his
father living on in his children as they
tinkered with the piano he said with his
mother that when he was in him in those
moments of grave danger in the Marine
Corps when he was deployed on missions
where he wasn't even sure if he would
come back alive that in those moments
when he felt that fear rising in his
stomach there was his mother that he
would think of because she was his
picture of strength she had raised him
in her his brother largely on her own
she had fed them and clothed them and
got them an education and help them
build a successful life and that to him
was real strength when he shared that
story to him it was so deeply moving
that five minutes of sharing built
relationships that we not built over
last year and within a few weeks we
started to see people stepping out of
their lanes and helping each other we
started to see people who had previously
been quiet in meetings start to raise
their hand and participate because they
felt that they were seen and that they
were appreciated for who they were that
was a very powerful moment for us so
workplaces that can create opportunities
like this semi-structured opportunities
for people to share more about who they
are that is very powerful there's one
other thing Tim that I want to mention
also which is that there's great power
in people helping each other in the
workplace and one of the stories that I
came across when doing research on
loneliness was there's stories and
they're in the research of of a
gentleman at the University of Michigan
Wayne Baker at the Business School there
who he's done a lot of work on
relational energy on understanding what
our interactions with other people do to
the energy we feel and how that energy
translates into productivity in the
workplace and one of the things that he
has found is that high quality
connections which can be lasting
friendships or momentary interactions
both can be extraordinarily powerful in
raising our energy level and one of the
things that really boosts that
relational energy is the experience of
helping someone else but also the
experience of receiving help from
someone else so what he did is he along
with Adam grant and a few others put
together a structured sort of tool
through a company now that they've built
called kavita's which allows
organizations to have an organized
setting where people can be a part of a
community where they submit a need that
they have and other people can submit
answers or offers of help to meet that
need and you can do this online you can
actually do it in person
and regular sort of gatherings in in
groups and companies but the point is
that the experience of
able to identify people's needs and then
have people step up to meet those needs
in a structured way can be
extraordinarily powerful and can
significantly boost relational energy
but the final thing Tim which is hard to
put into you know a specific protocol
has to do with culture in the workplace
and creating a culture of kindness and
compassion is extraordinarily important
if you want to build human connection in
the workplace and have people build
strong connections with each other and
that is not something you can just put
on your mission statement or your value
statement stamp it on the wall and just
hope it happens that's a place where
leadership by example really matters you
know people's despite all the cynicism
that we have in the world people still
do look to their leaders for examples
and when the leaders in organizations
treat each other with kindness when they
look you know to the people throughout
the organization give them time and
actually listen to their concerns
honestly and empathically that makes a
difference people take note of that
and so I think these are some areas you
know that can be extraordinarily
powerful in the workplace in terms of
how we build connection creating
opportunities for people to see each
other for who they are creating
opportunities for people who give and
receive help and helping to build that
culture of kindness and compassion
through example and through practice
these I think are the key ingredients to
building a connected workplace I love
the inside scoop exercise and and I have
a ia question about the specifics and in
one respect because I want to try this
and I will try this with my employees I
am lucky in the sense well at least in
one sense that I have a very small team
how many staff members did you have in
these all-hands meetings so these
meetings were meetings of our immediate
office so there were about 20 people how
did you pick the people who would go or
how were they chosen the goal was to go
through everyone in the office but we
started with and the people who as we
saw it were the least seen in the office
either because they were the quietest or
because they maybe work from home often
and people who didn't see them very
often
so that's how we started hmm it makes a
whole lot of sense and the company you
mentioned I believe co-founded by Adam
grant if I heard you correctly is that
give it toss like gravitas or yes okay
could you spell that I can take a stab
at it but it's or yeah if you wouldn't
mind just secure and we'll put this in
the show notes as well so people can
find it but just so that people know the
spelling yeah so it's in GI VI das all
right we will put that in the show notes
for everybody at Tim Doug forward slash
podcast along with everything else if
people wanted to pull their employees or
ask questions of their workforce are
there any questions that you would
suggest I know that that's not how you
approach this you were missing it more
on the observation that you described
but are there any questions or tools
that you would suggest for people who
want to check the pulse of their of
their of their team so a couple of
things I would suggest if you are
looking for an actual survey the Gallup
Organization actually does polls around
social connection in the workplace and
you can look to their questions as one
set of Sirte as a survey tool that you
could use the other survey tool that you
could use is the UCLA loneliness scale
which is a different versions of it
there's a 20 question version of it
there's also a 3 question version on
both validated tools but that may give
you a sense of how much loneliness there
is in your organization if you are
looking for one or two simple questions
the one of the interesting ones that has
actually been found to be quite useful
as an indicator and the Gallup polls has
been the question do you have a best
friend at work hmm and it turns out that
people who do not have a best friend at
work people who answer that question
know have significantly lower engagement
in the workplace and that engagement is
tied to productivity at the end of the
day and also impacts how people feel
about the company and their colleagues
writing it down and I promised earlier
lest I get chastised by my listeners
that I would ask you about
anchors and remember your anchors could
you please speak to what remember your
anchors means and also describe your
anchors and why they're your anchors
that's so interesting you're asking me
about can I ask you where that question
came from Tim yeah the question came
from homework I was reading a Forbes
piece and the that is where the mention
of anchors came up but you can't believe
everything you read on the internet so
perhaps I have been reading an interview
of Victor Lake and missus tributing but
I'll read what I have in front of me and
we can use that as a jumping-off points
so feel free actually I know what you're
talking about
and that was all right that was actually
Vivek Murthy not Victor Lake so we're on
solid ground here perfect Tim remember
your anchors is is a piece of advice
that I developed to remind myself
actually of often when I was in
residency and you know when I was in
residency training it was a really
intense experience for me I was both you
know dealing with life and death every
day I was seeing people who were gravely
ill who were my age and who very well
could have been me I was also though
trying to figure out a lot of stuff in
my own life I wasn't sure what I wanted
to do I was kind of going through yet
another identity crisis there trying to
figure out do I want to be a doctor 100%
of the time to want to be something else
so I was trying to figure out a lot of
stuff and I was dealing with a
tumultuous sort of intellectual and
emotional experience and in that very
unsettling ungrounded time in my life I
found that what I really needed was some
force and that would ground me in my
life and I began to think of those as my
anchors the forces that would keep me
tethered that would make sure that I
didn't float off you know in these
moments of hopelessness and worry and
anxiety and those anchors ultimately
were people in my life they were my
mother and my
my sister they were a few close friends
like my friend Hawk Hill who was my
roommate in college these became my
anchors and what I wanted what I tried
to force myself to remember in the years
that followed well after I finished
residency is that I need to be keep
tracking and keeping track of whether or
not you know I'm remembering those
anchors and reaching out to them and
staying connected to them because it
times in my life where I have felt
anxious and worried the times where I
felt just lost frankly of which there
have been many including very recently
those moments are often when I have lost
touch with the people like in my life
the people who are really the ones who
know me almost better than I know myself
the people who can remind me of Who I am
even in those moments when I forget and
I want to say that last part again
because that to me is a true definition
of a friend and this came from somebody
that I spent some time with in college
on an overseas trip to India to do HIV
work and one of these like late-night
sort of philosophical discussions I just
happened to ask him I was like hey hey
man what do you think real friendship is
about and he said to me just pause for a
moment he said a real friend is somebody
who reminds you of who you are even when
you forget and that is stuck with me and
those people are our anchors they're the
mirrors that we need during moments in
our life where our vision is foggy and
we can't really see our way out of the
fog and we don't know who we are we
don't know where we want to go we're
just lost and so anchors to me those are
people those are relationships that's
what we've got hold on to regardless of
what stage of life we're at it is easy
for me at least to forget Who I am
it's easy to lose lose the plot and
there's I suppose are probably shared
characteristics that typify the the
episodes in which that's most likely to
happen you mentioned a recent experience
of feeling
what was that what happened or for what
what what caused that feeling to come up
for you well it was when I ended my my
sentient government when I was no longer
Surgeon General and I was back to being
a civilian and I was trying to figure
out what to do with my life that was a
time of real difficulty for me I was I
was lost I was lonely I was probably
depressed I was unsure if I had any
value to contribute to the world and if
I did I was unsure how to actually I'm
sure how to actually deliver that value
it was a really hard time and you know
part of it was that and I even told
myself this during my time in office I
was like I'm here as a custodian of an
office and I'm the custodian of the
office of the Surgeon General but the
Surgeon General is not my identity
that's not who I fundamentally and
intrinsically am as a human being it's
an office that I'm occupying but despite
all of those sort of warnings and
admonitions if you will like they were
still sort of a shift in identity that
had happened to me when I was in office
where I think almost just by perhaps by
necessity you know we you know I I don't
want to say we I should say I like took
on the the trappings of that role and
and came to identify very strongly with
it I wanted to be a good Shepherd for
the office I wanted to set the office up
to be stronger for the person who
inherited it after me I wanted to do
those things but it became kind of part
of who I was and when when I was no
longer Surgeon General which happened I
mean we're being open here it happened
in a fairly traumatic way which I'm
happy to delve into if you'd like but
when it happened it was it was it was
difficult to sort of process all of that
and there was a part of me which felt
like because I no longer occupy that
office that somehow people wouldn't want
to engage with me or maybe they wouldn't
think that I had
value dad the word to the world or maybe
the same berry things that I had said
back then if I said them again with
somehow be less valuable because they
were not coming from somebody who held
that position there were all of these
thoughts often irrational thoughts that
were going through my head and and it
was really really hard to him it was one
of the loneliest times I've had since my
childhood I want to ask you how you
found your way through that or out of
that the things that most contributed in
certainly I mean there there's might be
a component of regression to the mean
but I would love to ask you about pieces
of the puzzle that that you found
particularly helpful for getting through
that period but just so my listeners
Minds don't run wild with all sorts of
imaginative scenarios could you could
you speak briefly to why the transition
was so traumatic you don't have to share
of course any detail you're
uncomfortable sharing but I do think a
little more context would be helpful and
frankly I'm also curious myself because
you and I haven't haven't spoken about
this mm-hmm
no we haven't yeah so I'll tell you so
doc this office the Surgeon General is
an unusual appointment in government in
that it even though it's an appointment
made by the president the term does not
end when the president leaves office so
the vast majority of political
appointments will end on January 20th
when the new president takes office and
you submit your resignation letter and
then you move on and you give the new
president the opportunity to appoint
their people that's how it works but
there are a few positions where that
doesn't happen they were called term
appointments so you're given a four-year
term and that may run into the next
administration but you you just serve
that term but you still serve at the
pleasure of the president so if the
president comes in and they say you know
I've got my my own person that I want to
to a point and I would like you to step
down then you know then you make room
for the new person so if the Surgeon
General is not the only position that's
like this the FBI director is another
they're several like in in the federal
government that have term appointments
now in my case
what had happened is that my term
technically ran until December of 2018
there was a new administration that
started in January of 2017
and you know for various reasons you
know I knew that it was the possibility
I might be asked to leave and you know
if that it came to that you know I
wanted to you know and to make room for
the president's pick but the way it sort
of happened was a was a bit surprising
to me because there was it was one of
those things there was really no
discussion sort of about it often there
is but it was sort of in the early days
you know probably four months and three
four months into the administration
where things were still a bit chaotic
people were finding their footing and
figuring out the building so one day I
had a meeting at believe it was three
o'clock on a Friday in April and I was
supposed to be meeting with with one of
the assistant secretaries and I walked
into the room and the assistant
secretary was sitting on the side not in
his chair and I was surprised but there
was somebody else sitting in his chair
and he said to me he said well you know
as of three o'clock you know we are
going to terminate you unless you resign
right now and I was puzzled because the
same person who was in that chair had
actually I had had meetings with him
before and he had said hey were really
excited to work with you on your opioid
initiative because the opioid epidemic
is a big problem it's a bipartisan issue
and we know you've been doing a lot on
the issue you've been you know leading a
lot in the country on it and we think
this is gonna be an area of
collaboration so I was thinking to
myself well yes you know it would be
great to work together on that because
it's still a huge issue for the country
so I was gearing up to keep working on
on the opioid crisis so I literally did
not expect that message nor did I expect
it from this person and so I looked at
the clock at that moment it was 307 and
I said wow if I would mean terminators
of three o'clock then that means that
I'm already terminated so I guess I
guess there's no point to having a
discussion but he seemed insistent on
trying to
to get me to resign and so it was this
sort of awkward back-and-forth where I
said well you know I I respect the
presidents you know decision of the
president would like to you know like me
to move on to bring his own person and I
said that it feels like it would be
inauthentic for me to resign and try to
claim that you know I wanted to spend
more time with my family or something
like that that's just it didn't feel
authentic it didn't feel like it was
real and I said you know with respect if
you wanted to pursue a termination and
if you want to appoint your own person
then just do that it's within your
rights like there's no one's gonna
question that it's fine and that's how I
left and so it was abrupt I never had a
chances say goodbye to my team and I
didn't have a chance I mean no process
you know what all this meant so it all
happened very suddenly and I remember
going home and I you know had a few
minutes to pack my belongings into a box
and I got into a cab and started going
home and you know what my first worry
was that popped into my head on the way
home was what are we gonna do for health
insurance or our baby boy it sounds like
a difficult difficult ride it was it was
yeah
it was and I was aware in that moment
Tim that what I was worried about then
terms of health insurance for our boy
and for the family was a worried that a
lot of people have around the country
every day we're teetering on the edge of
not having the health care they need but
in that moment you know I was just I was
just a dad who was worried about his
child and there were a lot of practical
things to figure out and the days that
followed one thing I didn't really do in
those early days is as I busied myself
with trying to figure out a lot of the
logistics is
I didn't really I think fully give
myself this space to process everything
that was happening it's a sort of a
reactor myself not just in my identity
but in the people in my life who had for
so many years helped me to remember what
my real identity was that my real
identity wasn't being a doctor it wasn't
being Surgeon General it wasn't any of
the titles that may have held that other
points in my life my real identity was
the human being I was as a friend and as
a brother and as a son did the people
that I loved it was the values that I
cherished in my better moments the
values of compassion and kindness the
values that are intrinsic to all of us I
think in our best moments like that was
really who I was
that was my identity but I didn't give
myself enough I think space and and time
and frankly I didn't I think I blamed
myself
also for for what had happened in some
way even though I'm a rational level I
knew that it wasn't my fault per se I
had blamed myself somehow maybe if I had
done things differently I maybe still
would have had the opportunity to serve
and to finish so many of the campaign's
that we had been building around the
opioid epidemic around loneliness around
emotional well-being and you know I was
doing all of this Tim in the absence of
community it wasn't because my friends
had shunned me it was more the other way
around you know during my time in office
I had I had convinced myself that it was
so important to pour myself into the job
because I never knew how long I might
have and I wanted to do as much as I
could and make as much of a contribution
as I could then I convinced myself that
I should just leave it all on the floor
and sacrifice everything for that which
meant not keeping up with friends not
talking is often with my family and also
I'm somewhat ashamed the same and that a
lot of times when I was with people I
loved I was distracted it's trying to
keep up with with messages and get
deliverables out the door and I look
back on all of that
and I started to realize what a toll
that decision that approach to my work
had taken I started to realize how
lonely I had become and how little
community I actually had and so I had to
live with that for a while I had to
figure that out and it was not easy it
was painful at times I felt ashamed you
know of having done this you know I I
knew I could just call up those friends
and reconnect again these are these are
friends for life
but I felt embarrassed that I had
disappeared you know for a few years and
it took some time for me to summon the
courage to reach out and to actually
pull myself out of you know my my shell
and my sort of downward spiral to just
say hey let's this is pick up the phone
and call a friend let's make it a point
to go visit you know somebody who's been
really in dear friend to me for years
but I haven't seen and doing that bit by
bit Tim that helped another pact I made
actually during that journey with two
friends in particular when we met at a
fellowship retreat we were walking
around this lake together and these are
two guys I love to death and they're
their break brothers and we never see
each other there very often because we
live in different cities and we were
just saying how awesome would it be if
we could just get together more often I
was like it's never gonna happen unless
we do something different so we made a
pact then we said you know what we're
gonna do we're gonna once a month we're
gonna video conference with each other
we're gonna make that commitment right
here right now to each other and when we
videoconference yeah well you know we'll
have fun we'll shoot the breeze here and
there but we want to make it the point
to talk about the hard stuff with each
other the stuff that doesn't normally
come up between friends we want to talk
about our health when I talk about our
relationships when I talk about our
finances the kind of stuff that everyone
worries about but that not many people
often feel comfortable talking to
friends about but we want to be real
with each other and I felt this hunger
for that kind of realness I was like I'm
tired of of trying to think about who I
should be I'm trying to tired of
thinking about like well my identity is
what my brand is like what brand I
should build like I had all
these people after we're telling me okay
you gotta get on social media and really
build your presence you got to establish
a brand so that you can get consulting
gigs and get on boards and do all this
kind of stuff and I just felt so unhappy
with that kind of approach it just
didn't feel like in feel authentic you
didn't feel real didn't feel like who I
was and what I craved was that realness
and so when I saw these guys I was like
let's just make a commitment to not just
spending the time but to be real with
each other and we've done that now for
about a year and a half I'll tell you
it's been one of the most powerful
forces in my life
and helping me reang ker remember who I
am what my real identity is and commit
to working on the things that truly feel
like they're in alignment with my values
the stuff that I would be proud to tell
my children about when they grow up
that's the power of what honest
authentic relationships can do and I'm
just so grateful for it I really
appreciate you being so vulnerable and
transparent with all that you just
shared I think it's it's really easy
speaking as someone I shouldn't
generalize speaking personally as
someone who struggled with depression in
during which the response to feeling
lonely and isolated is often to isolate
further which deepens the feeling of
loneliness as you said very early on in
this conversation it is a it is a
prominent feature of I think the or
common experience the very least of the
majority of humans who walk the face of
this planet it's it's not a reflection
of being uniquely flawed to have these
emotions and to experience these
episodes and it's yeah I just applaud
you for sharing because it's so
incredibly powerful when someone like
yourself who even though you you don't
necessarily identify as such who has
achieved very high levels of success in
multiple areas former Surgeon General
are willing to share that in fact you
also have gone through these experiences
I think in a way in nobles and
normalizes that experience for other
people so I really appreciate you
sharing all of that and it it actually
leads to a question for me and maybe a
comment and then a question so I was
doing homework as I always do for this
conversation and before I get to my my
comment of my question I'll give a pre
comment comment which is you you should
if you don't already I feel like you
could impact millions of people very
effectively and authentically with a
podcast so to be continued
as far as a conversation you may already
have a podcast and I'm just putting
putting my foot in my mouth but the
quite a number of people have been on
this podcast
Jaakko will Inc Calif us Minh Peter Tia
and others who have started podcasts and
I so far have a hundred percent success
rate at predicting which guests can do
well in this format so wait to be
continued and we can we can we can chat
more about that if you ever wanted sinks
him I'll of course yeah of course
and the the comment is related to a
Washington Post piece this is from 2017
and I'll quote here please feel free to
fact-check of course but this is
attributed to you I was at a well-known
university about nine months ago when I
was in office and I asked an audience of
400 faculty and students the following
question how many of you look at
emotions as a source of weakness versus
a source of power and nearly every hand
went up this is the paradigm we have to
flip in this country could you comment
on that please
or or share anything that comes up as I
mention that and also speak to how you
if you have been able to view your own
emotions as a source of power
he had Tim you know that was a
surprising moment for me and when I saw
all of those hands and I wrote a 400
people going up saying they associated
emotions with weakness and I think one
thing I've noticed in my own life is
that I have been in that camp often as
well if I think about growing up and the
messages that I absorb from the stories
that were around me whether those were
on TV or told by people or in movies it
was that especially if you're a guy that
strength is associated with suppressing
emotion it's associated with stoicism
and with not needing other people not
being dependent that's what strength is
and what I realize is that that didn't
work for me like I didn't enjoy being
the guy who's out there it didn't need
anyone else for anything because I
actually did need people for stuff but I
just felt embarrassed to say that
because I was told that somehow that
wasn't manly or wasn't strong similarly
I like in terms of emotions like I have
always been an expressive person I've
always thrived on emotions it's been you
know I've engaged in intellectual
pursuits but I know I'm primary
primarily driven by emotion and I feel
like that has been my source of power
not a source of weakness and so you know
in thinking about this I have and in
talking to others about it I've just
realized that our emotions are not a
source of weakness they are in fact if
used well our greatest source of
strength like when you look at an elite
athlete for example you look at someone
like Serena Williams or LeBron James
people I don't know personally but I'm
using them as examples my guess would be
that they recognize that the difference
between good and great is not just how
much time you spend in the waiting room
or on the treadmill it's about your
ability to translate your negative
emotions into positive emotions into a
source of power and that's what we do in
our better moments like you look at
parents for example who go through
extraordinary lengths even putting them
in harm's way for their children it's
because that's driven by the emotion of
love Oh an emotion that's far more
powerful than anything else I think that
we have out there
our emotions are our greatest source of
strength and so I think part of what we
have to do as a country especially for
our boys but especially a bit for boys
and girls is we have to redefine
strength as vulnerability as human
connection as belonging as emotion if we
recognize that strength can be drawn
from those moments of emotional
vulnerability then we can draw upon I
think one of the greatest resources that
we actually have you know it struck me
many times when or if I count my own
life and thinking about others that it
seems like there are two primary forces
that drive us in our life and they drive
the decisions that we make and those
forces are love and fear and fear shows
up in a bunch of different ways it shows
up as insecurity or jealousy or rage or
anxiety and love also shows up in
different ways is compassion as kindness
as generosity as warmth and when we lead
with love then we can transform other
people's lives we can transform the
organizations that we are leading when
we lead with fear
then that's corrosive that infects the
environments in which we work and the
people around us and when we think about
the decisions that we make as I have in
recent years started to do I asked
myself that question am i making this
decision because of love or fear am I
making this decision because I'm scared
of something or because I'm being
inspired by compassion or by generosity
or by kindness and I find almost always
if not always when I make decisions that
are driven by fear they rarely make me
feel good they often lead to poor
outcomes when I make decisions that are
driven by love even if they're risky
even if the
outcomes are unexpected I almost always
feel better and I almost always grow in
some way as a result of those I
mentioned this in particular Tim because
I think it is so important for us as a
society to be able to talk not just
about emotions but about love because
love is the greatest source of strength
that we have you know I as a doctor have
written many prescriptions for powerful
medicines and antibiotics but there is
no medicine that's more powerful than
love and you don't need a medical degree
or to be a nurse to be able to deliver
the power of love to other people's
lives what you need is the very human
and universal ability to respect and be
in touch with your emotions to summon
what's already inside you and that's the
power of love well said sir and I cannot
think of a better possible time for your
new book and that I say that with the
utmost sincerity I mentioned it earlier
at the very top of the show but together
that's the title subtitle the healing
power of human connection is sometimes
lonely world I feel like if this is
along with the message that you just
shared possibly very good medicine for
our times certainly with with what we're
facing which is in some ways just
bringing to the surface and magnifying
that which is already there I feel the
loneliness certainly a pervasive
loneliness and I would love to I would
love to hear anything you'd like to say
about the book it's a hell of an
undertaking to write a book yeah I do I
specialize in writing phone books for
God's sake so I write a to write a short
or a less-than fun book is even harder
since one could argue that I should
better edit my own writing and I'd love
to hear anything you'd like to share
about the book and why you would pursue
such an undertaking given what's
involved you know Tim this is not the
book I thought I would write I had a
couple of other ideas for other books
that I was convinced would be the places
I should focus on but
you know a funny thing happened to me in
in 2017 in the summer I wrote an article
for the Harvard Business Review on
loneliness in the workplace and you know
I wrote it the request of the the
editorial staff who thought that their
audience would be interested in
loneliness I said are you sure and they
said no we're not sure but we think it
would be of interest and I wrote that
article thinking ok I'll do this and
I'll move on to the next thing but I was
really struck by the response to that
article from two groups from members of
the media who said from around the world
who said hey we think this is a problem
in our country too the messages from
individuals who said you know I've been
struggling with loneliness for a long
time but I never knew that there were so
many other people out there I never knew
what the consequences of loneliness were
to our health and even despite that
response it the universe kind of had to
whack me over the head a few times and
make me realize that this is actually
where I should be putting more of my
efforts because even during my time in
office it had just kept surfacing again
and again this issue of loneliness the
stories that I wouldn't listen to in
living rooms and in town halls all
across the country there were stories
about addiction there were stories about
trauma and abuse stories about chronic
illness and about violence and
communities but in the back of those
stories almost hidden from view were
these threads of loneliness
that would often come up and plea what
people would say was not you know hi I'm
Tim I'm struggling with loneliness what
they would say where things like this
they would say you know I feel like I
have to deal with all of these issues in
my life on my own I feel like nobody out
there really cares about me I feel like
I'm invisible these are the kind of
things that people would say again and
again and what I come to realize over
time is that loneliness is more than a
bad feeling but it has real consequences
for our health and if you look at the
research that's out there you find that
loneliness is associated with a shorter
life span you find that it's associated
with an increased risk of heart disease
and dementia
and depression and anxiety the
immortality impact if you will of
loneliness is similar to the mortality
impact of smoking 15 cigarettes a day
it's greater than the mortality impact
of obesity or sedentary living these
three issues smoking obesity sedentary
living these are issues I spent a lot of
time on as Surgeon General and sort of
my predecessors I felt far less time on
loneliness even though the health
consequences are quite significant and
you know as I just started to think
about this issue more even after I came
out of office I started to realize it
this is an issue that doesn't just
affect our health it affects how we show
up in life whether that's how we show up
in the workplace or how our kids show up
in school or how we show up in the
public square and dialogue with other
people and so it turned out that our
social connection is in fact the
foundation on which we build everything
else and I came to see that I wanted to
work on strengthening social connection
in the world because if we could do that
I really feel that we have a better shot
at improving people's health that
enabling them to live the kind of
fulfilling lives that all of us
ultimately really want but I think to do
that to build a world that is powered by
human connection we've got to make some
difficult and very intentional choices
about the kind of culture we want to
live in and about the kind of workplaces
and schools that we want for ourselves
and for our children and if I had a
credo Tim for this book it would be this
it would be put people first that simple
philosophy put people first is I think
at the heart of what we need to build a
people centered life and a people
centered world and that's the kind of
world where we put our time and energy
into our relationships it's where we
design our workplaces and our homes and
our lives around relationships that
matter
it's where the dominant culture whether
that comes through on the media or the
stories that we tell recognizes the
power of relationships and inspires us
to be real with ourselves and with each
other
it's where a culture recognizes that
it's one we're authentic and when we're
vulnerable that we build the true
connection that powers everything else
that we do
that's my hope for the world that's my
hope for my for my children and the kind
of world that they will inherit and one
of things it pains me most as the dad is
thinking about the moments where my
children may encounter hardship or pain
and knowing that I may not always be
there to support them or to hold their
hand or to hug them I know that that
will happen every parent deals with that
pain of knowing they can't always be
there for their child and that's why I
think it's so important that we build a
kind of world that will lift our
children up when they fall down
where people will reach out to them when
they're feeling alone to provide them
with the support that all of us need and
at various moments in our life so my
this is not a what I'm talking about is
not a subtle change in policy it's not a
new law that we passed that suddenly
changes you know the nature of human
connection this is a fundamental shift
in how we think about our lives and how
we think about our institutions and how
we think about society but it's a kind
of shift that puts people back at the
center and I think can ultimately
empower us to a much much higher level
of fulfillment achievement and what
we've achieved so far and that's what I
want to do Tim you know I want to work
on things that will build a better life
in a better world for all of us and for
our children if I can contribute in some
small way to that then then hopefully I
can in the final days of my life
like the patient's I cared for at the
end of theirs I can talk about the
relationships that I had I can talk
about the kind of world that I hopefully
made some small contribution to help
create and that would feel very good
well Vivek I must also say thank you for
not only the conversations that we've
had including this one but also for your
your emotional support and compassion
last week in my case you're deeply
compassionate kind and also calm and
calming person and I appreciate you last
week when I had a fever shortness of
breath and track off for 24 to 36 hours
then shortly thereafter sort of
coinciding my dog having what appeared
to be exactly the same symptoms that you
were so available and understanding as
of course we ended up rescheduling given
that I was feverish and not in a proper
state of mind to conduct a good
interview so I want to also just
publicly say thank you for for that
which is a sort of microcosm of the
macrocosm in the sense that it's
reflective of what you are hoping for
and aiming for and helping to foster
with your certainly your message and
also the book which is together and just
appreciate you being you so thank you
for both the the personal help and also
what you're trying to do in the wider
world well thank you brother I
appreciate that that's it's incredibly
kind of you to say and I I know people
want to wave hello and ask questions
thank you for the interview they can
find you I suppose the home base is
Vivek Murthy dot-com I'll spell that Vee
I ve k mu R th why comm I can find you
on twitter at him so self-conscious
about saying your name now on Twitter at
UVic underscore Murthy and then facebook
instagram at dr. Vivek Murthy I think
the key is just for me to say it quickly
and not get too tangled up in my own
vocal cords I'm just glad you didn't
call me Victor Lake Jim I'm saying I'm
reserving that for special occasions and
the book as mentioned is together
subtitled the healing power of human
connection in a sometimes lonely world I
certainly recommend among other formats
get it in all formats but make sure you
get an e-book so that you can highlight
I'm sure there will be ample opportunity
is there anything else you would like to
share with my audience or say before we
before we close this this first
conversation on the podcast well I just
want to say thank you to you Tim I think
what you have done through your podcasts
and through the work you've done through
your books is you've created spaces for
people to to show up to be authentic to
have deeper conversations and that's
incredibly valuable in a world that's
moving faster and faster and faster
where who we are can get lost so easily
so I appreciate so deeply what you're
what you're doing and I'll maybe I'll
leave you with the one of my favorite
proverbs and all the African proverb
that says if you want to go fast go
alone if you want to go far go together
and I'm reminded at that as we talk
because I think that what we need to do
in our lives but also in the world is we
need to we need to go far and we're
facing some pretty big challenges as a
society and they won't be easy to
overcome but moments like this whether
we're facing a pandemic or longer-term
crises like climate change moments like
this I think are opportunities for us to
find each other to re connect with each
other to refocus on relationships and to
put people first and my hope is that we
will use these challenges to do that and
that women you emerge out of them that
if we are intentional you know about
spending time with the people we love if
we're intentional about making that
quality of that time high quality time
by reducing distraction and really just
focusing and listening to people if
we're really intentional Tim about
serving and recognizing that it is
through our service to others
we ultimately pull ourselves out of
loneliness and build strong connections
then I actually think we can emerge from
these crises stronger than we were even
before and that's why I remain hopeful
about the future of humanity because I
think we were designed to be there for
each other we were designed for
connection and if we refocus on the
relationships in our life I think we
will go farther and have a much more
fulfilling experience than we could even
imagine so thank you for this time
together Tim I really really enjoyed it
me too thank you so much and for people
listening I will have links galore lots
of resources anything that was mentioned
this conversation you'll be able to find
in the show notes at Tim dot blog
forward slash podcast and you can find
Vivek Vivek Murthy comm of course
remember your anchors and until next
time thanks for tuning it hey guys this
is Tim again just a few more things
before you take off number one this is
five bullet Friday do you want to get a
short email from me and would you enjoy
getting a short email from me every
Friday and that provides a little morsel
of fun for the weekend and five bullet
Friday is a very short email where I
share the coolest things I've found or
that I've been pondering over the week
that could include favorite new albums
that I've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up in
the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek comm all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you'll get the very next one and if
you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by
nutribullet I have my nutribullet about
seven feet away from me right now I'm
going to be using it for a bunch of
stuff tonight and probably tomorrow
night nutribullet is the affordable easy
to use easy to clean the easy to clean
part is super important blender that was
first recommended to me by entrepreneur
Noah Kagan when I interviewed him for
this podcast and specifically what I
asked him was what is the purchase that
you've made in the last say six months
for $100 or less that has had the
greatest positive impact on your life
and his answer was the nutribullet
nutribullet has sold more than 60
million units worldwide you can start to
do the mathematics pretty frickin
bonkers and once you've used one it's
easy to understand why it became so
popular with other blenders clean up can
they be a huge pain in the ass Miuccia
bullet makes it really really really
really simple and if you're not familiar
with the classic future bullet it's
effectively a single serve cop that
blends and then you flip it upside down
you detach it and you can drink it eat
it chug it down right there so it is
intended for at least in the classic
sense smaller portion sizes but give me
a second here so with your true bullet
as I mentioned cleanup is truly
hassle-free and their signature blending
process transforms whatever you might
have high fiber veggies nuts seeds
fruits of course in a silky
nutrient-dense smoothies if that's what
you like that are easy to digest absorb
I use them for nut butters I use the
nutribullet for soups of different types
that use it for all sorts of stuff now
the engineers at nutribullet have
created a convenient and upgraded
version of the nutribullet called the
nutribullet blender combo this is their
most versatile device yet because allows
you to switch between single serve as I
was describing and full size blending
it's also a bit more expensive of course
than the classic version but it gives
you a lot more
and from smoothies and protein shakes to
savoury soups and dips the nutribullet
blender combo does it all in two there's
a recipe book that comes with it there's
all sorts of stuff that you can play
with this nextgen nutribullet gives you
everything you know and love about the
classic device yes I'm reading copy in
this particular sentence plus all the
performance of capacity you would expect
from a full size blender don't settle
for blenders that leave your smoothies
filled with chunks or anything filled
with chunks that you don't want chunks
in get the nutribullet blender combo and
introduce your veggies and fruits and
whatever else you might have to 1200
Watts it easily just smashes the living
hell out of them and blends into
whatever you would like to create and
for you my dear listeners nutribullet is
offering 20% off of all products on
their website to get your 20% off just
go to nutribullet dot-com forward slash
Tim that's nutribullet n UT RI v ull UT
compost in if you don't have a
nutribullet in your kitchen you are
missing out it does a lot in a very
small package nutribullet compote / Tim
four-year 20% off this podcast is
brought to you by Trello during tough
times like these one thing that brings
us together of course is our common
humanity
and another which helps to harness that
is technology now more than ever
teams must come together and work
together virtually to handle challenges
opportunities and everything in between
that's why Trello is here to help Trello
part of that last chance collaborative
suite is an app for them easy to
understand visual format and tons of
features that make working with your
team more functional and more fun teams
of all shapes and sizes and companies
like Google fenders and Fender guitars
even Costco all use Trello to
collaborate and get work done it's one
of the few tools that has also made the
cut with my team but I just have a
handful
folks so it can work all the way from
tiny to gigantic with Trello you can
work with your team wherever you are
whether it's at home or in an office and
no matter what device you're using
computer tablet or phone
Trello sticks across all of them so you
can stay up to date on all of the things
your team cares about so keep your
workflow going from wherever you are
with Trello try Trello for free and
learn more at Trello comm slash TFS
that's TR e ll o comm slash TFS Trello
comm slash TFS check it out
you
[Applause]
you
you
you